now we're recording wait we mean
lighting up this up it what's up guys
just eating here Matt nadeshot Jenna
it's me Jenna II we're going to do the
blindfold where's your blindfold great
question one full cake decorating
challenge uh so this is all we have this
is what we have right here really piss
poor ha ha ha this looks like the
clearance section of groceries create
the proper utensils today right
what's this Shelton get let's get a
thing of sprinkles into flared section
no we gotta go do that no - again I'm
starting I got last thing I'm like we're
not even support risky Miramax eyelashes
are so longer
all right when did you make these today
oh I need a boo-boo already was all
right things are ready all right I got a
cupcake finally so we're just decorating
just decorating okay what's this okay
yeah I see one we're just decorating
mats are you just eating a cupcake over
there cuz I hear you chewing do you yes
I hear him showing your he icing at
least I have absolutely no idea I think
he's just sitting over there eating a
cupcake you were an idiot
why doesn't he eat one and then decorate
one how much icing do I have oh man I
can't tell I think here you chewing you
dumb pig I actually think that I'm
liking the icing off of the cupcakes I
get icing it so much I can't stay okay
don't worry I know where I have to go
but I'm not sure what are you looking
for don't worry about it
I can't find the cupcake oh wait
cramming it a little bit of this color I
think can tell where I'm at in space all
right
are you putting chips on it yeah well it
made a lot of noise all right let's get
another cup of cake mm-hm
I got one decorated already really that
grey one
I'm gonna grate a couple mmm these are
not funfetti sprinkles these are good on
sale I worked really hard to prepare a
nice that's mine what did you do are you
do you buy so festive hmm fun you put
chip on my thumb and hold hand in your
cupcake
now I see them again I'm just trying to
find this cupcake
I'd like to ice them and then add a
little pepper since I smell chocolate
like real close to my face
are you putting something in my face no
I can't see what I'm doing which one's
this much chocolate
I'd like to taste this oh man I try to I
think you're doing something to me
you're getting close to my face and I'm
a mile later I didn't feel I can feel
your presence they're not that good I
don't know what to do with my hands
Justine watch where you're going
I can't watch where I'm going I smell
chocolate Matt are you I didn't honestly
I can't look it's like I smell it oh no
my in your cupcake in here I'm cheating
I I have to disqualify myself from this
game neighbor wants his cupcake that I
made I have no self-control I just can't
do it I can't get my you what does my
cupcake look like who's gonna like one
of mine life dude what is mine say sweet
miss this was not didn't work well I
don't have any self-control I run the
game without using my myself blindfolded
oh I thought you were using chips
no that's it are you asking me that yeah
yeah I looked which one I wanted to get
a nice I thought I thought you're going
to get chips too because I was thinking
about taking some spicy Doritos my I'm
not a fair player I can smell chocolate
well because I made I keep that okay no
I was blindfold right off the rib I went
for I made cupcake and not this a first
hand it
you guys may find my belly hey some
selection hey guys thanks for watching
I'm not even sure what happened I had
something in my mind I pictured that was
going to work out much better than this
and it didn't so nice but give a look
that does look good so have you guys
have a good day
let me know the comments below if you
have any other video ideas because
clearly this did not work well why are
we even talking that's great
see you later ok stop I'll have more of
this though yeah I will